was in high school in the leadup to the
2016 election and we just had a scorge
of cancel culture explode even though we
were still teenagers and I at the time
was more worried about boys in acne than
than Trump but we we I saw that in Mass
scale um for the first time it was
really frightening to me um and frankly
as a result I self-censored for a while
and by the time I got to NYU I knew I
was in an ideological minority as a
wring libertarian here in New York City
um and I actually started hiding books
Drew my bed when I moved in cuz I was a
a new freshman and 18 and trying to be
friends books Thomas soul and Jordan
Peterson under the bed banished which
they're now loud and proud out on my
shelves and we just did Jordan
Peterson's podcast so cancel me now
please